le 4 août dernier de 1750 tonnes de
nitrate d'ammonium explose dans le port
de beyrouth suite à un incendie
bilan plus de 200 morts et 6000 500
blessés le port et des milliers de
logements de la capitale libanaise sont
détruits le produits explosifs étaient
entreposés dans un hangar du port depuis
sept ans aucune précaution n'avait été
prise par les autorités malgré les
alertes lancées à plusieurs reprises
depuis ce drame une enquête judiciaire
est en cours pour comprendre les dessous
de cette catastrophe
fadi sawan le juge libanais chargé de
l'anc est inculpé ce jeudi pour
négligence et cause de décès les tout
premiers dirigeants politiques parmi eux
l'ex chef du gouvernement libanais
hassan diab
hassan diab a la conscience tranquille
il est sûr d'avoir les mains propres et
d'avoir géré le dossier de manière
responsable et transparente
ce ciblage surprenant va au delà de la
personne et attaque le poste de premier
ministre en tant que tel hassan diab a
fourni toutes les informations dont ils
disposaient concernant ce dossier le
juge sawan viole la constitution et
contourne le parlement hassan diab a
démissionné quelques jours après
l'explosion du port de beyrouth poussé
par la colère de la rue
une démission certes mais l'ex premier
ministre continue de gérer les affaires
courantes du liban en attendant la
formation d'un nouveau gouvernement
trois autres dirigeants sont également
inculpés ali hassan khalil ancien
ministre des finances puis youssef
fenianos et ghazi zeaiter qui ont été à
la tête du ministère des travaux publics
et du transport
selon une source judiciaire le juge a
décidé de les inculper pour ne pas avoir
pris les mesures nécessaires pour éviter
l' explosion dévastatrice et les énormes
dégâts
le juge fait 10 à one pourrait commencer
d'ailleurs à interroger hassan diab
lundi prochain et les trois ex ministres
les jours suivants au total 25 personnes
notamment des responsables du port et
des douanes ont été arrêtés dans le
cadre de l' enquête selon les autorités
libanaises
sauf que le pouvoir en place n'a
toujours pas publié de conclusion quatre
mois après l'explosion du port de
beyrouth
la classe dirigeante qui refuse
pour l'idée d'une enquête internationale
sur cette affaire pourtant les appels à
des investigations indépendantes au
liban tout comme à l'étranger se sont
multipliés